well it looks like the universe found
something worse than death being my
mother yes the show that's just about
the only good thing with the name
russian on it at the moment is back with
a new time traveling twist that shakes
up the formula from season one in this
video we'll be taking a look at season
two's ending its timeline and how many
krugerrins it takes to alter the very
fabric of time season two takes place
almost four years after the events of
season one which saw nadia volvokov and
alan zaveri break their groundhog
day-esque time loops and return their
lives back to normal but time isn't done
with them yet whereas season 1 saw our
characters repeat the same day over and
over again season 2 takes a completely
different approach where supernatural
trains transport our characters back and
forth through time but not only that it
transports them into the bodies of
different family members but why is this
happening as nadia's grandmother vera
says in episode 3 there are things in
life that cannot be explained but we're
going to try to explain anyway while
vira nor the show have the answer to the
magical trains portion of this question
what's more important is why this is
happening to nadia in particular in
season one that time loop chose nadia
because of one thing that was holding
her back that was guilt nadia felt
responsible for her mother's death about
a year before her mother nora killed
herself nadia is given the choice to
either live with her mentally unstable
mother or ruth nadia chose ruth and this
culminated in her mother killing herself
hence this guilt season 2 however asks
what if we could fix that if only nadia
could go back in time and change
something so this future never happened
as chez says in episode 2 in our house
oconee island is the thing that would
have made everything better
if only it had happened so what is
nadia's coney island for her it's
retrieving her grandmother's 150 gold
krugerrands worth what she thinks is
about 280 000
by today's standards these are south
african gold coins that her mother stole
from her grandmother and by nadia
bringing them back to her grandmother
she thinks she can close this crazy time
traveling train loop vera chose gold
krugerrins instead of putting the money
in a bank due to her distrust of
government and the banks growing up as a
jew in world war ii hungary she knew how
easy it was for bank accounts to be
frozen money stolen and personal effects
seized these coins could be easily
hidden and because gold isn't tied to a
specific currency their price wouldn't
be in danger of hyperinflation nadia's
attempts at retrieving the coins from
her mother in 1982 prove fruitless she
eventually manages to retrieve them but
when she sees her friend allen on a
similar time traveling train she leaves
them unattended and the bag of coins
vanish it seems whatever force has
brought her into this situation doesn't
want her to mess with time so when nadia
figures out she can go even further back
in time to when her grandmother was in
hungary in 1944 she believes she can get
the coins back yet again and that's
exactly what she does traveling back to
1944 and taking over the body of her
grandmother who has taken the name vera
volvokov in an attempt to hide her
jewish last name peshawar the person who
helps her with this transition also
gives her a cross as it seems vera can
pass for a christian nadia's search
brings her to a storage facility in
budapest where thousands of items
forcefully taken from the jewish
population are resold to the public
veera's family was told they would be
given these items back after the war and
was even issued a receipt which nadia
finds hidden in the back of one of her
family photos this of course was all a
lie but at least this receipt has the
crate number of her family's possessions
you'll notice that the krugerrands
aren't in here that's because the items
stashed in her bag haven't been pawned
yet for them but another problem remains
how does she safely stash these items so
they can be retrieved by her grandmother
years later this is where laszlo kiss
comes in he's a hungarian priest who
nadia saw a grave of in 2022 hungary
covered in small rocks a jewish custom
because laszlo wasn't jewish it could be
assumed he was a friend of the jews due
to these rocks placed on his grave nadia
makes reference to this being done to
oscar schindler's grave in schindler's
list so nadia stashes her family's
possessions in what appears to be some
sort of sewer and gives the map to its
location to laszlo to give to her
grandmother after the war and that's
exactly what happens the very first shot
of the season is vera retrieving the bag
of possessions nadia stashed away
decades earlier but all of this hasn't
solved anything in fact by meddling in
the past all nadia has done is create
the very future she sought to disrupt
she is caught in another time loop one
in which everything she does leads to
the same outcome turns out
couldn't change anything at all so i i
can only do what was always done so
nadia has one last hail mary of a plan
in 1982 she's in control of her pregnant
mother when she has the baby ironically
on the platform of a train station what
if she took the child back to 2022 with
her that way she could be her own mother
and give her the mom she wished she had
as you can imagine this goes terribly
wrong as the very fabric of time itself
starts to collapse when nadia emerges
back in 2022 with the baby she
experiences multiple timelines as if
time has fragmented into multiple
potential futures there's one where ruth
gets in a car accident and one where
ruth has a pulmonary embolism one in
which she finds nadia's dead body
covered in bees which was one of the
deaths she experienced in season one and
one in which she finds alan dead likely
a result of her not being there to
prevent his suicide in season one you
may have also noticed the time periods
crossing over like people from the 1940s
in the background of the hospital in
2022 or alan being able to use his cell
phone in the 1980s the clearest example
of this is nadia's apartment which used
to be a jewish school meshing with her
36th birthday party but it's nadia
finding out ruth has passed and that she
wasn't there for her that puts her over
the edge everything she has done so far
has been for nothing not only was she
unable to change the future but nadia
didn't even get to say goodbye to the
quote best mother she ever had however
she kinda does in the final train
sequence nadia pulls young ruthie aside
and says you had no obligation but you
love me anyway
hi ruthie even though young ruthie has
no idea who she is nadia gets her
goodbye and this time loop finally
closes when nadia comes to the
realization that her past cannot be
separated from who she is as alan says
to her can't escape being the product of
things we can't change this is
symbolized by nadia literally giving
herself over to her mother nadia has
accepted that she can't change the past
and it has given her some closure see in
the end
nothing can absorb us but ourselves the
same can be said of alan who traveled
back in time in the form of his
grandmother to 1962 east berlin there he
found his grandmother involved in a plot
to smuggle people across the berlin wall
but even when he tells his lover lenny
that the wall will eventually fall lenny
still risks his life and goes through
with it no matter what allen did the
outcome would still be the same for
allen this is his coney island if he
could prevent lenny from going across
the wall maybe things would be different
for his grandmother yet whatever he
tried the outcome was the same and lenny
leaves when allen and nadia realize
their pasts can't be undone they're both
hit by a train and sent to the void a
pocket where time doesn't exist it is
here nadia is confronted with a choice
she sees a baby and a bag full of coins
however she only has the strength to
carry one does she choose herself as
signified by the baby or her trauma as
signified by the gold it's this scene
that she literally lets go of her trauma
and chooses herself allen has a final
talk with his grandmother agnes who
gives him a pep talk saying that he
needs to stop worrying and learn to live
even though he may have imperfections to
her he is perfect there's not much we
know about agnes whether this is
actually her or some figment of allen's
imagination but she seems to be someone
who can travel through the timelines and
has an age considering she would have
been born in the 1930s or 40s the name
agnes comes from greek meaning pure and
holy she guides people through the
underground like how she helps nadia in
episode 3. religious and mythological
symbolism is used heavily throughout the
series even nadia is directed by literal
guardian angels when she first emerges
from the train with nadia's arc complete
she emerges back in present day a month
after her 40th birthday ruthie has
passed but nadia has now come to terms
with her death and is at peace with
herself just take a look at the last
shot of season 2 compared with the first
shot of season 1. we've come full circle
however this time nadia is trying ever
so slightly to smile finally having
gained control of her life but what did
you think of russian doll season 2. i
want to hear your thoughts and theories
in the comments below be sure to like
and subscribe and for more bad takes you
can follow me on twitter and instagram
at thingstoryyt until next time remember
nadia you cannot uncook that baby's just
bring it